في سودان اكد رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان القوات المسلحه لن
توافق في مرحله الاتفاق النهائي للعمليه
السياسيه على اي بنود يمكن ان تنال من
ثوابت البلاد بحسب تعبيره وفي اشاره
للانتفاخ الايطاليه الذي وقع في الخامس من
الشهر الجاري قال البرهان في خطاب امام
افراد من القوات المسلحه انه ليس هنالك
تسويه سياسيه بالمعنى الذي يفهمه البعض
في اتفاق فيه نقاط عسكريين يقدر على بيها
نشوف انه هذه النقاط او هذه الامور طرحت
هي امور بتنقذ بلدنا وتطلعها لبرا الامان
عشان كده وافقنا عليها وانا ادعمه وحاله
سنين لغايه
لكن اذا كان في حاجه بتمس الجيش وبتمس
القوات المسلحه
الذي وقعه المكون العسكري مع بعض القوه
المدنيه على ترتيبات الحكم في الفتره
الانتقاليه وقال البرهان من القوه
المتوافقه عليها في هذا الاتفاق يمكنها ان
تمضيه بالبلادي الى او تمضيه بالبلاد الى
الامام
لان عندنا قوات اوافقنا عليها دي هي القوه
ممكن تطلع البريد لقدام ما ناقصه ما ناقصه
ناس القوه هذه المتوافق عليها هذه اذا
جاءت قعدت انا متاكد قدام عشان نحن نقول
لهم مافي زول يحاول يختطف هذا الاتفاق ما
في زول يحاول لمصلحته الاتفاق هذا لكل
السودانيين وكل القوه اللي احنا توافقنا
عليها انها تيجي تمشي مع بعض وتشتغل مع
بعض عشان تطلع السودان هذا الحكومه مدنيه
من المستغلين دايرين الحكومه المدنيه
شامله يمثل فيها كل الشعب السوداني دايرين
الحكومه نقول له الامانه